this is a production of Cornell
University today I'm gonna talk about
you know like a joy since I've been
actually looking back genome editing
ever sings to someone lying at the post
or almost 10 years I just cannot imagine
but today I were really gonna share some
result after you don't have as P I you
know in past few years a lot of exciting
you know progress just share some
results with you so overall my lab is
really are working on sort of a genome
editing but we actually extend that more
than genome editing so we actually also
engineer sort of engineer Synthetica
transferring activator repressors to ten
oh and turn off genes which are have
their own advantage compared to existing
technologies so and we start a little
bit I don't want to talk anything about
this yet it's very preliminary we also
want to do epigenome editing to change
the you know the epigenetic mark of
histone modification DNA methylation and
but you have to keep in mind that the in
the end you know even these epigenome
attitudes here you wanna change the
expression so rather I think making
synthetic air you know just regulator
isn't is there a motorway so but again
giving today's topic kind of time I
actually gonna limit my talk on genome
editing we can talk more if you're
interested in later we can communicate
on this this topic
alright so for genome editing so to
achieve that it's rather easy to start
because you have to start thinking about
can you engineer a very specific or
tailor-made a scissor I quoted magicka
molecular scissor to my daughter for
example explain that why it's magic
because you can engineer that to
recognize any DNA sequence as you wish
in the genome
whether it's mo genome in out across a
huge genome like in wheat and so so that
has been a problem we call sequence
specific nucleus because you know that's
involved a lot of protein engineering
how can you engineer because DNA
sequence change letters right so that
has been a big big problem until lately
when I like stop ten years ago you know
or little more than that people have
making some progress but after you make
Tom's jump break with whatever scissor
you have really that literally just
introduced Thomas from break so DNA
double strand break is a very laser
damage of DNA so compare other breaks so
it has to be
hair immediately before the sale cycle
can be continuing and replicating DNA
can continue so so two pathways one is
only actually a pathway called a
non-homeless and adjoining pathway which
literally just sticking together stitch
together you know eventually using like
is like like it's flowing like is the
broken DNA together the the pathway in
fact I can argue is very precise okay so
you wouldn't make mutation but if you
make precise repair and it can be
recognized by the same scissor again
it's gonna cut again and making you know
repair many runs the runs of discount
singalong and eventually and you will
make error make mutations so that's how
you introducing their insertions
modulations that's how you're not
coaching many of you I think in audience
can use a technology no coaching
nowadays and for reverse genetics or
other purpose so but another pathway
which kind of used mine early sort of
whirring humans as well as in higher
prices for the homologous recombination
or homology directed repair HDR this
pathway typically is used in homeless
chromosome or histo chromatin stiff
series replicating and to repair
precisely the broken DNA and but we can
sort of were taken about into this
repair pathway by providing a door no
more ocular which share sort of homology
on the left and right then what's
worrying between the green stuff
highlighted DNA sequence can be inserted
copied into the information which really
representing the precise genome editing
so when we talk about precise genome
editing we more rest we're referring to
this kind of pathway unfortunately this
is really the pathway has been hard to
achieve because it has been utilized
there minor in the serve so when I first
started of course this is a question we
kind of want to kind of try to overcome
and if you think about genetically you
know if you can block this pathway and
let you pass by making some mutation of
the gene in this pathway probably gonna
shift the pathway to a yes so there's a
kind of one-way when I even as poster I
did it knowing at the time we are not
really lucky as you guys have Swiss per
we only have linking a nucleus so we
engineer zinc finger nucleus Tutera gene
in the background of Koscielny cous
Emily and equate aging are just really a
the Jing are involving this an HD
pathway and now in the coup 70
background which means an HD pathways
abolished and we indeed we found
actually and we use the same finger to
stimulate
the repair of HDR and in DD we found HDR
frequency has jumped at tenfold higher
but even that is the single digit
and this is a story being done in
protoplasts which means o matic sir not
really German lying whether we can
achieve that you know like a genome
edited HDR plant you still open question
I was saved at to the very late in this
talk to mention this again how can we
achieve HDR plant which are germline
transmittable all right so so start from
zinc finger nucleus and then later on we
have tannin which is again the the lab I
worked with John Waters group along with
other the invented Talent Technology and
but that really still stays very long
and later on being replaced by Chris
podcast a cast nigh and more recently we
have CRISPR CTF one so for the sake of
today's time I really gonna skip all my
earlier work with zinc finger talent
rather give you some taste of Chris
podcast and Christmas EPF so when I
start my own group in North Korea I see
you first
whistling searching either my first or
Levi's joined the lab so at the time
just happened to be Chris podcast 9 has
to be already become a proven technology
I even pass with some 13 so that's so
but from there we look at as amoeba I
look at what can be done we found a lot
of nothing can be further improved
researchers ask you need a better tool
so that's kind of a motivate us to do a
one topic you this which is here we
develop system called a PCR free
assembly of market expertise system the
system rather simple and basically what
you end up having a sort of different
step you have a module of guide RNA
which you can basically start with a
pair illegal which you can order you
know and then you can be you insert that
into a vector each vector is modular we
can you know depending how many sites
you want to target and if you have three
sites you have three guide on a
different free module and using one
single step of building it groaning
together a quarter guide on expression
vector this guide on expression vector
is now is also gateway compatible vector
so now we can utilize all the resources
at hand research community have occurred
over the years of the gateway vector you
all have in the lab and then because
gateway vector allow you to have
different promoter which is pro to
promoter which can be inducible you know
also consider t'v or tissue specific
right so this promoter can now hook to
drive different caste nine for example
we have entry and chrome which have
Oh countess 9 which are codon optimize
the form on foot I caught human or
anything or a custom Iong derivative or
you know gene repression or activation
now you can really have them Oh in this
sector now just three way k2 in reaction
right you can put them together this
this is entering chrome this is to enter
guide a guide on ancient Cologne cast na
engine chrome the destination vector
always different promoter now you're
making a single T DNA you know deliver
using typical agro transformation this
is how you work with this I'm quickly we
we have to demonstrate that when we
publish papers how it works and we for
example
asama free guide RNA and to targeting
one gene to make a deletion and one just
making a single knock out this crouching
in a post case we can show cheese yellow
crack you can have phenotype which means
by alan ik knockouts very efficient and
then we also this is mike robbery to
cruz cavite humans and group in china so
we also wanna you know use that for
other things for example what i showed
you here is coding gene protein coding
gene what about non coding gene like
small RNA or micro managing or or long
non-coding RNA gene because that would
renewed a recent interest in this kind
of area right so so we actually have
evidence in this paper if you are
interested so we we show that even by
introducing a small one base pair
insertion deletion in micron EG actually
likely you're not gonna abort the
function micron is still gonna work so
the one safe way to actually knock out
micron a gene is actually a conduct
deletion by using double strand break at
this big five and three prime end of
this gene and making her chunk of
deletion now you can really make sure to
leave the micro energy and we did the
time up alright so deletion now you have
a six day you know you have sixty
percent right people 20 lying it can see
any of you have 12 deletion happen right
it's very efficient and this one is 20
percent but still it's very achievable
writing rice this is rice making
deletion now you can knock out my
chronic and two studies function and
then you ask me you know what about
other advices people have have been you
know cannibal use that a lot what about
the plan I worked on I'm just no even
paper published about genome editing how
can I do that well don't worry because
we have the tool have a lot of cash line
we have like six seven cast nine
what my customer you could test and then
for example this is group my
collaborating : either Rafa so he used
our system basically a billion
scientists come to my lab at the old
assembly and also other things learn and
we make all the vectors and for example
here just showing you three well this
Arab have scrutinized may is good ohmic
mice and a pant couldn't cast nine and
then you apply two carats and knock out
again the gene f3h gene is involving you
know this as a sounding accumulation in
carrot so if you look we start with the
high accumulation lying if you look at
this gene out they become white okay so
this actually this quantitative looking
at color cannot tell you how efficient
different cast on you assemble because
literally you do much work only on the
last step of gateway crooning you're
just using different cast nine you make
it just already had a much work at all I
mean in the ending but now even test a
lot of reagent then he concluded this
cast knowing optimize and applause has
worked very well carrots this is how you
can do and another example is a
collaborator Cameron group I was State
University and so we again here just
design just you know to guide RNA to
target to sites in the year to GE maze
and so should test that two different
construct and then we found that
efficiency is very high in just guide on
a mediating one hundred percent every
single plant is knockout and many of
them if you look carefully or by an
enigma codes okay
and then another guide RNA is ninety
ninety percent no code also very high so
he basically after she saw the result
she told me that if you know you know we
published people in crack Jonah last
year reporting a cast nine system you
know for for maze researchers but your
system seems better so she said well you
know so that's actually good because the
tool allow you to optimize the system
but we never really stopped you know
making better system so when this casts
nice a crisper cpf from our system has
been reported at 2015 I become very
interested for a lot of reasons and just
highlight a few of here focus for
example this CPF on protein is unlike
has nine kustanai making brunt and
cleavage three base pair away from the
ngg Pam sequels you all know that maybe
and then but sepia phones differ
just like zinc finger nucleases talent
that I have been working on it's
actually making a staggered end with a 5
gram and over hand if it's ripe if we're
making three primer behind which is
better for Jeff or HDR pathway Bastyr
you know the stick end there may be
really useful for example maybe you we
can use nhej a pass weight really sort
of inserting a donor DNA sequence so
making precise gene replacement and
Lewis well things like that and this has
to be has to be done you know in class
not many people yet published but also
CP CP f1 unlike Cassadine system it
actually only utilized a crispr RNA
which is like 43 nucleotide along for
CRISPR cast 9 we typically using single
guide on it which is fusing of Chris
Pawnee and the tree Solana together
right
it's a much longer like 100 base pair
100 this is much shorter and also CPF
one recognize the polity which is tea
tea tea tea Pam and which is a nicely
complement to the mgg pan of seek cast 9
so CPF one base we can recognize more 18
which genome or a bit recites and also
it cut away from the Pam
which means if small mutation induced
there maybe the guy Ronnie can still
recognize site and cut again which can
stimulate the further you know if we
pursue HDR maybe can stimulate the many
runs of cunning so this is really a very
unique so that become very interested as
so again my poster without being really
developing CPF one the first thing we
tested we just apply the same thing how
we express forecast lying with the same
thing with caste CPF won and we in
particularly we express gate on a with
you three u6 promoter not enough working
well we just don't know why we spend
time troubleshooting and in the end that
we compared many systems and the system
come out very nicely so the system we
eventually worked out very well is
though I call that do report to promoter
system because we are using the same
promoter of poor to promoter you'll be
cooking promoter for maze and to drive
the CPF on protein and what we test it
is a s and ARB because these two protein
just happen to be the one show activity
in human cells we just follow those
things and then we also use same
promoter to drive the guy as a crisp RNA
or here's a problem because for pasta
promoters
unlike hopefully promoter like you three
start with a new six Thomas G it's very
hard to define the first nucleotide of
transcription and also we already based
on our failure I will see Pierre from
earlier we have kind of well already I
think that this crisp money has to be
precisely processed in order to retain
very high activity to do that we use the
two ribozyme which is hammerhead
ribozyme HD visor and for students here
representing you know it's self cleavage
on a right so just like enzyme so now
with that so you can imagine this
transfer will be processed by self
cleavage after making RNA and then this
precisely processed at they find the
lens of guide on and we now we're
compressed with you know CPF own protein
and then act to recognize DNA
genomically and making double strand
break and indeed this is case really
working nicely and here I just show you
six sites here and where you can see
every worked very nicely but a s half of
them working half even working so seem
to be some but ARB is robustly working
and then we look at what kind of
deletion mutation make and overall those
a s and ere be making over 95% are
making deletions instead of insertions
okay they're mostly elysion and in fact
deletion are actually sized are larger
sizes about marriages ranged from six to
certain based population which is
interesting because forecast nine we
typically in rice this is typically find
they're like one two three base part
addition ok this deletion from CPF form
is much larger and which can be
explained by a staggered end that's more
and processing after double shrimp break
so so what's really exciting for us is
really you know we have to show whether
we can make editor the paths right so
you make it we making a grow mediator
transformation of making cheesy low-rise
pants and excitingly for the plant we
have surveyed and 100% not cut every
single plant is not hot and what's rare
astonishing is really that almost every
single plant is by an enigma code which
which means already none aloo okay
because those copy of chromosome
question has been knocked out because
rice is deployed
and so this is really exciting so and
then you know this is air BCP f1 and
then of course then you know other
research including Cameron are
interested in so we collaboratively we
show it's also working knockout gene in
mace so you can imagine you have now
another tool Christmas EP f1 for genome
editing and but you know the thing is
the CPF one not only to prefer eighty
which region but the pam that the one
working with a s and ARB nucleus in
human cells are really prefering TTT Pam
you know you know if you're such a
genome or gene of interest it rather
hard to find the triple-t right so you
know it's really limiting you and so
then when I have a new post or join the
lab ensure so she's actually asked
question can we really making the CPF
one system more accessible we can find
more tal sites in the genome in the Jing
of interest then it will be become more
use right that's kind of obvious
question but then if you look at many of
this indeed it there's actually quite a
few CPF on protein so the broken has
only TT d Pam instead of TTT V the V
just Stan in any nucleotide and opti
like a CG okay T TV so but the only fnc
p phone has been shown some activity
hume implants and we look at literature
that's only one single site which is
actually edited by f and c PF Onias t TV
so all the site is actually GT TV so
although other research acclaim fnc p1
recognized you know t TV there's no data
backing that so then we want to
systematically look in this problem so
so first we look at as we just look at
many sites ten sites here which are t TV
p.m. and then we design another
different difference of guide RNA which
are utilizing TT TV Pam so for F and C
if your phone clearly as you can see you
know the TT TV Pam the sites are really
more show more activity you know editing
activity so it's compare the T TV but
the inner some T TV works some not
really working which kind of puzzling
but on the other hand it's kind of
suggesting that maybe hidden lore which
are dictating the activity of CPF form
recognizing T TV p.m. this is kind of
make us to chase
you know make robustly working at ttv
site but before that we look at how CPR
from editing at a titty titty TV and TV
side compare so this is the two ttv
sites and this is TT TV sites overall
they making very similar profile is the
deletion this is kind of where the
condition occur and this edition size
and if you look deeper most of deletion
actually are kind of repaired by micro
homology of DNA so then we also look at
the specificity because one big problem
is a specific would that be any of
tightening problem any of us you know
you know using CRISPR cash we asked this
question so one thing - one way to look
at instead of looking at hormonal
homeowner sequence in the genome is just
you can we can make mismatch and guide
RNA and to targeted the the same time
effect and then we just make these every
two mutating every two nucleotide of
making mismatch occur on a as you can
tell most of the guy tonic or burst
function completely only at the very end
like the nucleotide at 2122 nucleotide
and you actually see very similar
activity which kind of suggests you know
when we design crispr RNA for CPF one
especially for f1 CPF one maybe we don't
have to design like 23 nucleotide alone
okay because 22 seems 21 seem to twenty
actually maybe already working but
overall I think it's they're very
specific they could earlier mismatch or
abhorrest function this is at t TV said
this is actually TVs at same similar
conclusion so but then we haven't really
answer why f1 GP f1 worked at some T TV
side some are not so it's kind of steer
puzzling so to do that we are look at we
basically you need this approach we
search rice genome to find the exact
same proto space the proto space are
basically just target sequence of 23
nucleotide we just looking at rice
genome to find exact same site okay to
perk eater here and they are different
chromosome same sequence and also both
also have the CRISPR Pam
except one is T V T TV the reason is we
are hypothesizing at adjacent the
nucleotide may also play a role of
impact in the function of CPF one that's
why we call it in bttv because only
difference is one is having extra t1 is
lacking extra 1t
otherwise the whole sequence is same but
they are just located in different
chromosome different sites in the genome
so then we let same a guide on a guided
to recognize both sides look at
efficiency so we look at that I don't
have to show you data because actually
published us last month's paper I just
don't have to go through but overall we
found it s in factor f and c PF
unrecognized most of VT TV although
about different activity here but they
mostly fail to act on GT ta and a city
pc sites so if you want to design if you
want how in f1 with there you know you
try to avoid these two sites that's kind
of a conclusion but how can you find
another way to make sure you can tackle
more sites in the genome besides just
truncated you know TT TV to t TV so
actually a fun dance group and last year
I have shown the engineer that some
variant of ASC pf1 as well as ABC and to
recognize the for example making the are
variants just different amino acid a
change in the protein now the protein
can recognize cccc or T ycv Pam just
changed so we kind of want to apply the
same variant test in our system or
they're gonna work and here's a result
and over oi
yes it's working we actually also
introduced a mutation based on protein
structure to effing but we enjoy the
less success but overall the red one
showing is air be our variant over all
work very well recognizing the cccc
three sites or working but then many
many sites of T ycv and then different
varying a quite decent activity input
process but but the FN variant and not
really you know that active but nobody
has ever published anyway we figured
maybe that's other Runet and then in
that study that also should RvR variants
and then you know which recognized the t
ITB and as they claimed also recognized
ta well yeah TI TC and th EG we tested
both but we didn't really find it
working in th TC probably found it
shoulda you know three a two out of
three sites and both FN and air be this
avi are variant can recognize th e g so
this is kind of the data from rice again
but but you what I wonder ask you know
what about making can you make edits you
know stable a transgenic mass or you
know even without Shastri
we of course did it just this is summary
but I just want to don't have time to
run through but over I just want to give
you the information is like you know
whatever we see something working in the
proto past somatic sir and then we can
almost deduce what is gonna work in a
stable shattering past or not I even
have base our system is very reliable
very much correlated for sings not
working you know it's gonna be zero
percent but you know I just want to
pilot here for example this ABC the are
variants recognized GTCC you know we we
got almost nearly 100 percent knock out
it's very efficient if you know
targeting those sites but overall after
this work and originally we start with
the air be an F and CPF one we know they
reliable and recognized tttd which is
like it just many sizing the rice genome
and now with you know FN c PF one we
defined where which kind of work VTT
deep ham they can target and now we
quickly expanded it to success many
sites and now we further engineered
those air be the are variant you have
this many of blue sites and then you
have the you know air B's avi are
variants recognize th eg the overall we
kind of concluded with our newer agents
you Co job for the sites you can target
it compact originally you have and we
did a similar and asking our abductors
more or less the same now I want to
shift gear to Australia because you know
many of you are really interesting of
targeting especially not only for this
plant research but also for biomedical
research like human gene therapy right
application of Christmas so but one
thing I want to brought to you in here
for the nature same journal nature pant
actually published controversial papers
2015 is published correspondence saying
you know it's very safe because well so
not virus if not much of targeting found
by whole genome sequencing and it could
have mice mouse and then last year
published another paper you know like
okay no we found a lot of kind of
collateral damage due to maybe Cassadine
protein seems a lot of targeting lot of
OS and these it's covered in the genome
of editor Mouse the beauty of the system
is the only sequence to one animal which
is being genome editor I I think the
statistic as the sample size too
smoothly or agree right so although they
included a few parents are you know
control but even
or this thought it kind of control
become the control animal become a
questionable so that's why you know if
you are meeting the news last week it
retracted which is no surprise you know
and nature nature mr. pubb's editorial
actually specifically addressing
retraction of this paper and they also
publish like five a challenge paper to
show why just paper has to be retracted
analysis how Express being design I'm
not very good so this paper being
retracted and and what's it really
interesting for me is when you read the
editorial that the editor concluded are
you know still to this day that's your
very little work a prior genome
sequencing to look at whatever animal
organ it has been genome modified to
look at whether cast nine or CPS on have
Clara damaged in a unit not much work
has been done it's kind of like they
conclude that so well that's actually
that's true or have to but in fact you
know we actually was Clarita we about
three years ago we already sort of
thinking about this problem potentially
you know and about less than three years
but almost three years ago we started
thinking how can we answer especially
because this question has to be answered
in a good way then we can progress sort
of data to the research community or
even to regulator like FDA or US
agencies so what we did is actually we
we design a bunch of like twelve guide
RNA forecasts nine and we collect them
we test those casts nine protein for
different activity in rice ranked hill
from very relatively low that 25% of
activity based on how many cheese
illa-llah you scored how many are being
edited we score that efficiency okay if
you have ten a 100 a 925 being edited at
25 percent but we also have cast nine in
some Thai sites one a person every
single lines being modified edited and
then we have CPF own protein which being
modified that one represents because our
system very efficient so and then total
we have twelve
guide on a forecast nine and three guide
on e4 c PF one so then what we do is we
making comes will be making a lot of
transgenic modify the plant which is a
rope ramp and then we based on the edits
we choose editor plant we followed them
a to TL C 0 because some edit plants
still contain the transgene still
expressing the nucleus
whether constitutively expressed nucleus
were little
another question mother but the forest
experience most important seeing is not
like getting these lines it's really
about getting the contours right this is
the mouth study contact so for us we
really include a lot of control for
example we know slowly just having see
the from cedar you know from one
generation to generation by nature you
have mutation so that's why we actually
prepares regeneration of rice seeds from
2015 to a 16 to 17 so regeneration of
rice seeds from Sita - Sita and we also
look at tissue culture because the way
we the genome editing is tissue cultures
are about your transformation in this
case and then we have craft which is
have a grow bacteria infection no a grow
and we also have you know planting
infected with a block contained cast 9
gene without together on a and also
contain CPF own gene which I'll get on
it and cast 1900 kind of control and we
sequence independent a two-line each for
these control and these four lines for
these control 12 line here so then many
many lines here to de we sequence about
17 lines total and you know just give
you some idea this is actually the
another self control plan they don't
have to pay much attention the point is
we we try to use all different three
different software looking at to court
in there's insertion deletion as well
snips and just to be sure so so this is
just look at only your overlap to
further tool for further analysis and we
have we did it for you this is just
welcome show but we did for all the
lines and here's some data so the data
first of all we are interesting whether
we have mutation from city to city of
course you know if you cry seeds from
seeding rice in our case we found about
20 mutation you know over India s only
snips SMB and also about 20 insertion
deletion half half basically marriage
for a mutation just hot from cedar to
seed which is happen randomly if you
want to look at where they located or
just random in the genome and then we
know character with a tissue culture in
tissue culture in fact introduced about
here is a 100-ton e s and these snips
and about here is like a little bit
lower than 100 like India's it's a
barrier because we have tissue culture
only almost every bacterial infection
only and a backbone only as it seems
Avila bacteria resulting little bit more
in insertion deletions but we don't want
to claim that we want to be careful
but we still sing awesome one size may
be still limited but overall you can
tell on average you know the doesn't
really seem to be you know on average we
show you a lot of mutation just English
control panel you have to treat this
country a mutation as background in any
plant being modified by genome you can
express this it's never message about -
hungry mutation in the plant you editing
rice okay
and the question is what about all
really editor pants so this is stacking
the editor crammed together this very is
just cast nine the the green is CPF Wong
you compared to those backbone only as
you can see a ver äj--
here so this is SMB this is in there on
average they're more a similar ok it's a
similar level and so if you look at
whether you have one inky Dean search in
two or three because we haven't have
some line even have three TD insertion
but I have overall eighty percent of
charge in fact only have one single TD
insertion so that's the beauty of all
about your transformation system very
limited a number of copy number of T DNA
but nevertheless we can finally you know
T DNA you know not copy numbers nothing
really contributing how many mutation
you have okay and then we also we happen
to have a few construct which
simultaneous express more than one guide
RNA we do perks that we'll talk the two
sites in the genome and we also found
that those even expressing duper guide
RNA
doesn't really seem to be you know
having more mutation compact a single
guy tonic and so really there's no
correlation we did a more correlational
but I want to skip those things and so
but but the conclusion is very clear
then we look at now we are limiting to
about 200 mutation every single plant we
have right now it's very easy you know
we almost know this mutation mostly due
to tissue culture because we already
found in the control austere we can look
at individually each each mutation
whether really they are off targeting
you to cast an eye or sepia or not and I
have to tell you only one site from cast
nine we find evidence we found a
mutation you need a tingle of perfect
this is because we purposely designed
130 guide RNA because we designed that
way and because we figured out if we
don't find anything it's rather
disappointing right so we designed a
guide RNA which has kind of off taliking
potential like PCR primer not really
perfectly doesn't a few other sites in
the genome will be in the only one or
two mismatch we know that and indeed
suicides infinitely
those guys can be luckily predicted by
any computer software right you can
produce that but for you it's good
because now if you can avoid the also
conclusion we have used if you can make
your guide RNA your second occluded
skate on it compared to your own target
again RNA if the if the off starting
Kidani contain at least two mismatched
compared to your guide RNA you are very
safe it's very unlikely to be edited
this is base RT the whole genome
sequence data and then we find another
new mutation another line have mutation
but easily we figured out just from
parent align because there's no no
evidence of any you know similarity to
the guide RNA and all the mutation we
discovered is like s and we rather than
searching conditions for the inserting
deletion is the trademark of Cassadine
or CPF own technology mostly insertion
creation rather than s and these but
these are mostly snv's we know it's most
like a pogrom mutation and we just
happen to be overlooked from parent and
lying even though we see with so many
parents austere you know that's
variation among parents you miss you
overlook some mutations but this is only
one side over all although 15 guide
honest we only find a 130 guide on
resulting of poverty it's I think the
conclusion is very clear like we think
it's very safe I don't say say but off
timing is very you know negligible
almost
so we then look at the t-one plants we
don't really find any just having cast
nine constitutive expressing in the pan
if the cation is specific we loan really
have evidence of any accumulated
mutation so it's even safe to express
them in the plant
constitutively so here now i've already
covered a CRISPR cas9 system my lab
developed and applies I mean different
plant species at high efficiency level I
also introduced you a crisper CPF form
and more importantly I share the most
recent data about of targeting and so
far good so it's very premised it's
really promising as really a promise in
my title really we can use an opening
rice tomato many many other plants if
you imagine you know luckily you know
you know recently the US do you have
regulation they say we are not we are
not gonna regulate these genome but in
France likes more insertion deletion
anything you can achieve by commercial
breeding so USD also make the
announcement recently all data are
really packing announcement but I at the
beginning I also introduced you know
this this hot
to make this is another challenge right
so how can you achieve HDR you know hire
highly efficiently and of course you
know I continue to do work many is good
I started because I want to achieve this
high efficiency but everybody you know
in the audience may also agree Arab love
Sally Jana is really a racist for study
but I have to conclude it may not be a
great system for Ginny emeriti but but
the wheel it in hard way and I'm gonna
share I don't have time to share you
with data but this is what we did it
will very try different reagent in arab
doses to really try to stimulating the
genome editing in out of doses so this
is work actually traveling with my
former mentor time for it was at
minnesota so so what we get are
basically we try the zinc finger nucleus
here on crispiness and we express these
reagents at inducible promoter and also
consider promoter and even mayo to the
promoter and we try to talk him because
gene certian by extra we tried knocking
a Jing with BA
Gus and GFP different marker gene a
different drink different loci in the
genome and so what we really and we even
using viral replicas replicated donor
DNA and we try the many many things but
we can but in the end what we found is
we find many lines some lines have very
high evidence of HDR in somatic so if
you take Harris positive if you evaluate
gene editing by HDR yes it's present
sometimes something I have 50% has based
on the viral replicant system but then
we have a seeds from the plant to score
them whether they have event German are
transmitted I'm sorry so it's rather
disappointing we only have very little
success so what what's really so that's
why we found a big disconnect between
somatic and germline HDR events you know
disappointing it's many years work we
further you know hope only for the money
we spend on that or full of people for
the work but also for the community a
lot of people take things for granted
it's easy to do in arab doses we sing we
better reporters even a lot of negative
data so only way we feel it may be to
report get it published maybe by the
letter to editor you know just because
you have a fully asleep supplement data
or negative you know maybe that's one
way to go but anyway we write a letter
we think maybe that's where you know
report i think i see i have some
hypotheses but i don't have
time to discuss I think that's about
dinner repair about how what cancer
you're editing but luckily what we
concluded here is that may be the better
way right now is achieving cheating in
America HDR is really to editor the
pants like from somatic cell like
catalyze Cal I and then regenerate
depants out of that rather than harvest
seeds from like Anna blossoms a little
different because you throw at it so
luckily all the plant we are working
actually mostly goes through tissue
culture I think that wouldn't facing
this problem that's kind of good aside
Bastyr I believe or the plant when we
you know a pride genome editing more or
less we have to overcome their own
problem you know relative a species
which has to be worked out individually
and nevertheless I hope you can convince
them we are at the end of the beginning
of genome editing because we're at the
end because we have for most of you you
have enough to knock out a gene of
interest if you only want to knock out
but you know we are at the beginning of
applying them to many many plants which
are kind of exciting I think but another
thing is about how can you make better
crop a product right so so I think
another limitation is that can you get a
you know access to the elite cut you
need to nine like among Santo other
Apple a big company they have right now
then if you have that maybe literary
academic laboratory can do genome
editing you know you know people can
grow them you know especially now it's
not regulated maybe you could say that
means how much market who knows I mean
that's a lot of potential right that's
why I say you know what he make a lot of
people very excited but whether you can
you know do that in jump as much as
quickly to collaboration so if I end so
so one work we I did with a collaborator
tapping sounds broke he has to LeBlanc
is in China was in Australia so with
them I'm being signaling in his lab what
we did is we are not coaching he has
been worked on many years CSA G and this
Ching if you knock out this gene we is
Chris podcast now in this case and it
actually the trait is actually in them a
sensitivity so the mutant work them in
this case if you grew that in the show
day the the pollen basically is either
unfertile in fact in photo not
pollinating but if you're growing a
short in in a long day and then it
partly become photo now you can
basically switch the Commission and
making a pollen for tell what's a big
deer but that actually
knowledge behind a two-line hybridize
system very nice because rice harvest is
conventionally rely on three lines you
have to have a maintainer lying to give
the one which are still up right that
one can you know you know receiving
other but now we actually can making the
same line
just switch condition becomes still out
or in stellar so this is actually
technology behind a two line so this is
one way we can apply this we can the
point I want to make here we can
calculate making them edit in the unit
lines they didn't really can I just show
you one here this is a Wi-Fi abuser you
later nine farmer Road you stop my area
of Sean - Graham you know it's really
lying the jump lands people are using
right so this is part of reading you to
really apply Chris podcasts and more
recently collaborator humans and we
worked on similarly instead of one gene
we can target L you know mark or cutie
urging right because see the trait see
the size here the can be determined by
many many genes but now we can you know
multiple using all cost retargeting many
genes at once and true cat not only
tired of many genes but also technology
in elite lines
okay so theory just like 3 to 1 J is to
elite 9 anyway so and then you can look
at the industry any time you can get
single three single mutant double mutant
s and then triple mutant and IA variates
the gene worker because we I mean we
what we's out of doses or the motor
parenting program we think the Jing of
function can be translated easily no not
the case even in their eyes even if you
go out drinking rice in some other
species if you're putting definitely
later 9 may be different we have to
evaluate that from gridding point of
view
indeed it we finally in a variation for
different rated trait you know we
evaluated even same gene ok so this is
again highlight the importance not only
working we interact but you must almost
have to test them in uni trying to see
whether really the performance of treaty
introduced really good or not ok with
before I end I because like I said I
don't have time to do it
introduce any other tool because but you
know we already published three papers
about you know making activate or
repress of regulated genes and this is
three years ago and last year were
published another paper on you know
repressor but see peso CPS found a
strong repressor to repress gene of
interest of transmission ever and a year
later earlier this year we published
another work we repurposed act
you know to make a stronger activated in
first paper active aging we even
repurpose the Tarot system to make our
typist
gene activation if you are interested I
encourage you read this I can make the
resource available in fact all the
passes are available at antigen that's
why I cook knowledge that we try to make
food available to all the researcher
even before publication that's kind of
what do we do and with that I would
really want to thank first of all
startup from two universities and the
company and the NCBI technology it's in
Janka support my previous research and I
sometimes forget to mention all the
collaborators in my slides I go too fast
I really want to approach all of them so
every single you know project is
collaboration without them not possible
and a lot of people in the lab data's
hard work I will stop here so take any
question if you have thank you
[Applause]
okay yeah I think to answer your
question I think first of all I think
either way will work if you even design
single guy on a it worked in your plant
of Jing of interest making edits but you
know of course it's the most likely it
is different in there or whatever
station right have different events if
they all abortion function basically you
know what they got and then they give
you same phenotype I think that's fair
to say it's strong enough compared to
even the two independent Anoka because
if you sometimes if you knock out gene
cation energy maybe not fully abortion
functional but gene protein right so so
it's very very that depending what kind
of situation are talking about yeah yeah
along that's lying it's really hard to
address because the more is better in
that case more independent is better and
the but if off timing you know it's due
to very much same commerce string you
are being being edited because katana is
falling same sequence maybe still you
cannot really know yeah overall trying
more is better and
III don't really think this is debating
anything from conventional genetic even
EMS honestly because you know
Commissioner you have to do
complementary you know you have to make
it white up gene back to the mutant to
show it's rescue the phenotype I think
if you can show that you do better even
with Chris podcasts
yes equipped at all with any of the
adenosine images crisper Sanders yes I
do but I don't have data here so yeah I
welcome that yes yeah of course
if published I mean I yeah so yeah yeah
so this c2t basic editing and recently a
2g based editing yeah that reminds me I
have a couple mask of review on a 2g
there's a lot of eight with people
following a 2g people David a little
published a few months ago about a 2g
based editing and but I have to say
overall this base editing system are
lower efficiency compatible if you wanna
know how G a compared to it just just
using Chris Picasso at have nucleus okay
second of thing is a based editing seems
to be over promising from izing sings
because it claimed c-to-t or a 2g
changed but in the end in that window of
a few new trader NEC can be changed to T
any a you really are being limited that
you have to spring a lot of round design
catering carefully you to me you know
it's not great yet so they still have to
you know wait work out window narrow
down or proto mean is that different
application but my lab is actually
looking I think based I think we have
based anything we have a lot of
application for promoter bashing for
sure that a lot of other things or or
you want to spring a naturally evolving
disease resistant gene I stimulating
change you know across coding sequence
of our gene you can imagine but to me is
the system has to be made better I'm
working at with you know so yeah it's
not that efficiently yet it's working
yeah yes Lee the question sorry the
question here is usually you will need
to transformation you get like 10 to 20
percent transmission efficiency how can
you get to even like 100 percent the
editing efficiency okay here's a
misconception basically what we look
tears we first look at the plants which
are transgenic in this case sort of
select already and among all the plants
are edited as then we can say 100 edits
yeah if the wrong even don't hire a
transgene we don't count because not
raspbian not to even have a reagent so
yeah yes that's ok there's a casting
casting is RNA editing system you know I
have less interest in that because I
have my own thinking and because I have
synthetic artificial transferring
factors I think those are really better
to me you know two years on in cleavage
in cleaving you know reagent but then
there's other system of the company are
developing so I have heard about but but
these are more or less like CPF one yeah
yes you want your slides you show the
picture of hair which is a woody plant
so for many plants with highly rights
and self incompatible right so you think
of the way to get around this issue look
to get rid off their guide array and and
some astronaut and Jenny yes as a
there's a lot of ways one way is give us
DNA and maybe you can find some edits
but just happened to be no stable a you
know you can use okay you can you can
edit without the T DNA integration right
other deal ever DNA but the gene be
they're expressing the reagent but the
DNA wouldn't be really inserting
chromosomes and we're become you know
after you you're making a path out and
then you can deliver with RNA but Ani is
unstable right that's right people are
more using an T the ribonucleotides
delivery the you purify Cassadine
protein and envy to just you know
incubating tests to be with guide RNA
and you boom bow is jingle all the way
you know on nanoparticle to achieve that
but to my understanding those things are
being worked out but not official yet
yeah
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at Cornell edu